talk about demonic program that's going
to sit yes the gap well it's been
determined online just not in physical
reality and so yes I'm going to be
talking basically this talk is the
extension of prakash's talk which I was
very pleased when you gave that talk
because I was like brilliant I don't
have to introduce my talk I can just say
what Prakash said about doing semantics
for physics we've done in one example so
what I'm going to talk about is some
work with Sampson that we did on taking
the logical structure of a certain class
of or a certain set of operations that
you can get in a very basic theory of
thermodynamics and turning it into a
programming language complete with its
own semantics that you can actually do
computer science with in order to do
physics so we prove things about physics
using the computer science tools of
things like verification where ification
so as Prakash said well Prakash said I
should put this this way that there's
many similarities between the logic of
semantics and the way physicists do
physics and I would say yes but there's
also an awful lot of differences in the
way that they actually perform physics
so with physics you start off with these
laws of nature and equations often
differential equations and you drive
solutions from them and that can be
using more or less black magic it feels
like at certain points there's nothing
in the equations themselves that tell
you about their own applicability that's
where the physicist comes in whereas
with
programming you sort of start from the
ground up you've got a syntax you've got
a semantics you can derive allowed
statements from that and then if you're
doing things like verification you find
invariants so those are two quite
different ways of looking at a system
and it's not immediately obvious that
they might be useful to go to put the
laws of physics into a programming style
of logic and part of the reason for this
is that when you look at programs and
program logics is very very logically
it's it's all that if that's the word it
now is it's all you can go from one set
of statements that's true to another set
of statements that's true and there's
very little arguing about it whereas
physicists have arguments all the time
and you know you've got this set of
equations and you argue about how you
can apply them and sometimes you have a
theory that is a set of equations and
those equations don't necessarily relate
to each other and we find this in
quantum mechanics that's kind of a
canonical example with the Bourne rule
which is that that the square mod
squared in the ounce which amplitude
wave function is equal to the
probability that you find in a
measurement now that is completely
independent of the rest of the equations
quantum mechanics but it's really
important because that's how you get
probabilities out that's how you derive
things like no signaling and there's
nothing in if you like the laws of
quantum mechanics that tells you when
you apply that so you have physicists
who just somehow know when you apply it
and you physicists argue amongst
themselves and at the moment there's no
there's been no way to formalize that
process it's simply you put a bunch of
physicists together and they argue it
out
and so how could we take that process of
argumentation around rule laws that are
agreed on and formalize it so this would
be to try and do the physics equivalent
of what you do in automated theorem
provers for maths so things like
Isabelle and [ __ ] so you can see from
that it's hard enough getting maths into
that kind of logical structure of what
mathematicians actually do it feels like
you know good luck doing that with
physicists we're even worse so
operational theories though are a place
where we could have a crossover where
rather than this top-down you've got
laws of nature and equations that you
have just sort of dropped from the sky
and how on earth could we relate that to
a syntax and semantics well what if we
looked at theories where we just have
allowed operations and we're trying to
compose those allowed operations and we
will know what equations those
operations satisfy but we're building up
our physics rather than taking it down
from the top and that's what we've done
with this example of very very basic
single particle thermodynamics and his
reference so view of the time i'll just
say very briefly there's this guy who I
love I've just come across him he was a
13th century computer scientist only
because he lived in the 13th century
they called him a mystic
and he was in fact the first person that
I come across who tried to do this so
logic in his day was syllogistic logic
and it was it was very much involved in
the language and can you take
propositions to other propositions
whereas he wanted to find out about
nature and so he tried to come up with
essentially a process logic for all
natural science not using any of those
terms obviously because he was in the
13th century but that's that's what
ultimately this what I'm about to
present is is pointing towards this idea
of moving away from starting maybe with
axioms or with laws of nature that come
down from the top and can you formalize
the processes that happen in physical
systems and that give rise to physical
laws so what's the system that I am
talking about I said it was very very
simple thermodynamics single particle in
a box and you would think this would be
completely boring and there was nothing
to say about it but believe it or not
this single particle in a box has been
argued about for coming up to 200 years
you know what what can you possibly can
you get out of this what can you do with
this and it's really really simple
because you've got a single box a single
particle you've got a partition that can
come in and out and you've got Pistons
that can slide in and out and the
equations that they satisfy very simple
so we've surrounding it with the heat
bath temperature T which means T is not
a variable which is great we like not
having variables in physics and so we've
got the pressure of this single particle
rattling around the volume of the box
which is either one or a half depending
on whether you've got the partition in
and there's an entropy and so entropy is
a measure of the disorder of the system
it's this moderately horrible equation
so X is the probability of being in the
left-hand side 1 minus X probability of
being right hand side and these are the
two equations that govern the motion of
the of the or govern the state variables
and particle in the box so you think
that was you know it's obvious what you
can and can't do with this so there's
there's also too if you like big law
whoop sorry there's one big law in one
posture that so the second law of
thermodynamics you probably heard of it
if you haven't heard precise
formulations of it no net extraction
work without an increase of entropy
that's one way of formulating it you
probably heard entropy does not decrease
over time that's another way for
formulating it and then for the purposes
of this talk I'll talk about Landau's
erasure postulates because that's the
way into what we're doing with this
system and so what Landau suggested is
that you can think of this particle
being on the left or the right is a bit
you know maybe 0 if it's on the left and
one if it's on the right and he
postulated that if you want to erase a
bit of information in the system you
have to increase the entropy by Kalon
two postulates not been proved so where
we come in is that people have been
trying to take this very simple particle
in a box and prove whether or not
Landau's postulate is correct just just
for this system remarkably that is
incredibly difficult to do and just to
give it a flavor of just one set of
discussions that people have had about
it these guys norton and lady man i'm
not going to go through this this was a
great big ding-dong they have
produced you know mountains of paper
it's a great way to get lots of
publications getting an argument with
someone and then argue you know back and
back and forth if anyone feels like
doing that see me afterwards so
essentially one side was saying you
can't you know a less Landau's posture
that is correct you're going to violate
the second law of thermodynamics and
then the other guys were saying oh well
you violate the second law of
thermodynamics with those basic piston
and partition operations anyway and then
we're going oh no you don't oh yes you
do and it was a rather a Punch and Judy
or um sort of kind of a spoiler
duplicator vibe going on there but there
was no closure to this because they just
kept on going back and forth and um lady
man James lady man that she came gave a
talk at Oxford and that's how we got
involved because Sampson came out of the
talk going you know I just don't
understand these philosophers why don't
they just formalize their system or I'm
having all these arguments about it so
that's what we did
they've gone on to talking about quantum
fluctuations which is code for nope you
know they've given up I feel like I'm
giving away physics secrets um so basic
points of contention are can you use
those basic operations to violate the
second law of thermodynamics you think
that was easy to prove haven't brain
haven't been proven before this and can
you set it up so you can prove that
whenever you array is a bit of
information in this system you increase
the entropy and can we in fact formalize
these two statements to be a little less
woefully so there's a very very basic
set of operations let's formalize them
as an operational semantics so we're
just going to take the allowed
operations in the system and make them
formal so first of all we have to
formalize the system itself we have to
give a set of configurations and state
variables so what we're going to do is
extract out the logical structure of
this system to try and and sort of take
a step back from the physics and just
look at it as a system of what can you
and can't you do in this system and how
do we write that we'll first off we need
to define the state variable what's the
minimal set of information you need to
describe the physics of that box system
it's actually this so you need to know
the probability of the particle being
found on the left hand side box because
1 minus it gives you the probability on
the right and we've actually just
restricted to three options either it's
definitely on the right it's definitely
on the left or we don't know where it is
with 50 50 probability is there a
partition is there a piston yes or no
those two a and I boolean flags and then
W the total amount work extracted from
the system this is discretized just the
physics of the system tells you it's
discretized into units of Katie
too that's it you can convince yourself
if you really want that that will give
you all the physics now we want to be
able to describe things that you can do
to those state configurations so we need
a syntax and this is I'm not going to
have time to go through this properly
but this is the way that we can get
statements and essentially the
statements are about these fields their
statements about the state probability
of being in the left whether this
partition whether this piston and what
the work unit has iterated to now the
important thing here is these are how we
compose our statements so we've got the
normal if you like sequential
composition but we also need this which
on the next slide when we get to the
semantics we'll see is probabilistic
composition and we've got an
if-then-else and everything else is
pretty this is this is based on the wild
language so you should be fairly
straightforward now these are the
interesting ones the operational
semantics so what have we got well like
I said everything's pretty much normal
this is sequential composition do one
operation and then another and then
another here we've got 5050
probabilistic on compositions so s1
compose s2 means that with probability a
half you do f 1 s1 and probability a
half you do s2 so what do the basic
operations look like if we for most
amusing this language so the first
allowed operation you can insert a
partition and what that does is it sets
the partition flag to true it's just an
assignment statement there remove the
partition so I'm going to go reasonably
promptly through so if there is a
partition then if there isn't a pistol
then your particle becomes completely
delocalized and the flag of whether or
not there is a partition is false this
is just giving you an idea that you you
can describe completely the behavior of
what happens when you do these
operations remove a piston depending on
whether or not there's a partition you
iterate the work counter whether it's
giving you out work or not and the same
for removing the partition to the right
inserting a piston slightly more
difficult I'm not going to go over why
if you want to ask me afterwards I will
say why we have a few extra things in
here but we have this is where are
probabilistic composition is coming in
so this is this is basically formalizing
all the different things that can happen
if you insert a participant depending on
where the the particle is whether
there's a partition but this is all
derived these are just the behaviors
that happen according to the laws that
govern the system so now we've got this
complete set of allowed operations these
six allowed operations now we can start
doing verification on them so the first
thing we want to do is find a
computational invariant so this is not a
physical quantity but a statement it's a
predicate that if it is true before any
operation then it is true after it and
that that is also valid through any
composition of these arguments so there
is something which there's something
called Hall logic that enables you to
prove this the proof is three pages long
I am not intending to give it here I can
show you it afterwards if anybody would
like to see it but you can take a
proposed invariant statement
you can prove using [ __ ] logic that it
is an invariant statement for the system
that any composition of those basic
operations will preserve that invariant
statement does anybody want to take a
guess what the invariant statement for
this system is
Oh
that's what you'd think isn't it it's
almost the second law and it may be the
second or in disguise but that's the
invariant statement so we what the hell
are these these are two different types
of n trapeze and please if anybody has
seen this entropic quantity here yell
tell me I keep on asking people what is
it physically if you put a minus sign in
there it becomes the Haleiwa quantity
but it's not the hell avo quantity it's
some somehow some form of generalized
entropy so an easy way of seeing what
the difference between those two entropy
Zyzz is suppose we have to computational
branches that's what the probabilistic
composition gives us is branching in the
car in the computation and in what
saying one of them we know that it is
definitely on the right and in the other
one we know it's definitely on the left
the particle then in both of these the
entropy is zero so the average entropy
is zero so it's the first of the two
terms but the entropy of the average is
K log 2 because the average of X is a
half
so if you add the two up then you'll
somehow getting both the entropy within
each branch and the entropy across
branch branches another way we could
possibly think of it is that the entropy
with the probabilities within a branch
are somehow the epistemic probabilities
they're the ones that are known and the
probabilities across branches are the
ontological ones they're the ones out
there in the real world but yes if
anybody has seen that before or comes
across it please tell me or drop me an
email or something so what can we do
with that invariant statement that
invariant statement is somehow encoding
the it's telling us something about the
law or is it a law you know it's telling
us something about what transitions you
can do with those basic operations
that's the statement that they all have
to satisfy but we can derive
consequences from that if you like
universal statement and the first thing
we can derive is the second law so this
is the Kelvin statement of the second
law there's actually quite a few
statements of it which is one of the
problems in thermodynamics so this is
saying you can't come back to the same
configuration and have a net extraction
of work so W 0 Z is the initial work
counter and WF is the final so if all of
your configuration other than that is
the same then you can't have extracted
work from the system and if we define
the zero point of the work counter to be
equal to this which you know we can it's
just a counter it doesn't matter where
we start from then the invariant is
satisfied and we know then we can just
turn handle on this configuration and it
drops out that's the final work
average across branches must always be
less than or equal to the initial so
based on that invariant with a little
bit of extra stuff so it's not entirely
it's not exactly the second law but you
get the second law out as a theorem you
can also get land our Asia out as a
theorem of the system and so what we do
is you have to define and I will go very
very quickly through this you have to
define what measurement and resetting
our because we will define AirAsia as a
measure then reset to a known system and
this is this is something that people
who've been discussing around our Asia
of kind of that's the definition of
Eurasia that they finally come up to and
that's what we find works here so a
measurement takes whatever you've got in
your branch in your branches and gives
you an exact values so if you start out
with a branch where you've got x equals
a half after a measurement you've got a
definite value so what a measurement
does is it zeroes the average branch
entropy what a reset does is it zeroes
in the number or it takes the number of
branches to 1 so that is resetting it
definitely to the left so a reset 0 is
the second type of entropy now we can
take the computation one variant and
figure out what the work cost of those
operations are if we've got an operation
that zeroes this entropy in order to
satisfy the computational invariant how
must the work counter change and what we
find is that in order to keep this
satisfied a measurement
must require at least a half KT log 2 of
work in order to keep this below this
total below zero a reset must require
also at least half KT log 2 of work this
is when applied to a bit and so if you
take an unknown bit of information and
you measure and then reset it in order
to keep the invariant satisfied you must
require at least a work cost that is
both of those just KT log 2 which is
exactly Landau's postulate so from the
computational invariant we have out as a
theorem the second law and landowner
Asia which is not bad I think so
conclusions what have we done we've
taken physics and we've made computer
science out of it or else we've taken
computer science and made it into a
process language for physics I prefer to
think of it in the second way around we
defined these basic operations and the
composition between them found an
invariant and from that invariant being
able to derive if you like universal
laws what any composition of these basic
boxes and operations must must not
satisfy so that that gives us another
way of tackling physics this is this is
completely different in feel and in
process to the way that we normally do
physics but it's one that I think can
give us quite a lot at the end places
where certainly I would like to take
this is to look at other areas of
physics where you can try and define
basic operations and to try and take the
rules of argument that everybody agrees
on take the formula and laws that
everyone agrees on and agree on a set of
basic operations and then find things
like
mutational invariants out of those so I
would love to see what quantum mechanics
looks like in this couple of brief
things how does this way of
operationalizing physics relate to in
axiomatization that's one reason why I
think looking at quantum mechanics in
this form would be quite interesting
because they feel in the certain sense
similar that you're trying to get down
to basic operations and then compose
from those but they are very different
because with an operational semantics
approach you're not you're not saying
these are the most basic you're just
saying here is a set and also with the
operational semantics approach you can
change the logic that you use to reason
about them and that leads into the final
thing which is can we use this to
automate physics in the same way that
we've automated some of mathematics I
understand why you have to first measure
before